man who's gonna be for a fourth straight
year a sideline reporter for the Super
Bowl on Westwood Ones radio coverage of
of it coast to coast he is none other
than Tony Boselli how are you sir I'm
doing great
Tony how do you see this one rollin a
week from Sunday what do you got for me
here well flip a coin Yeah right
I'll pick San Francisco but saleable to
Kansas City
that's no idea I mean this is gonna be a
great game it is so close you got the
great defensive line for diners and the
vacant effect cash bombs but we've seen
when they you know kind of middle of the
year when were the Chiefs offensive line
was beat up and they weren't healthy and
the offensive production went down
because you know you could get to him
you could affect them and he's human
he's barely human but if you get
pressure on and you hit them it's gonna
sell that off and down and the question
is can the t's protect and hold up
against that defensive line led by Nick
Bosa who's just a beast and so it's
gonna be a lot of fun to watch and kind
of see how this thing goes and yet that
you got the track team for the Chiefs
running around out there you know scored
a bunch of points you have one of the
best pass defenses in the NFL so I can't
wait to watch it yeah I mean and Damian
Williams coming to the for getting
healthy and then having a focus placed
on the run thanks to his effectiveness
might change things and you called the
AFC Championship game for Westwood won a
couple last Sunday and it did seem like
Kansas City decided we're gonna run the
ball in the third quarter and that
opened things up for the past and the
fourth to lay the hammer down I'm
wondering what you saw with your own two
eyes on that front well I think you're
right I mean I think the key to that
game rich was that last Drive at the end
of the half that 27 yard run by mahomes
with you know 15 20 seconds left
you know Rashad Evans is spying my homes
on that play get a chance to tackle them
at the line of scrimmage probably hold
them to a field goal and you're going in
tied in that game that thing just
changed everything it almost was like
all of a sudden you have the Titans in
panic because for whatever reason the
guy who carried them to that position
only got three carries in the second
half that's Derek Henry and then you
look at the Chiefs and they start
controlling the clock the very thing
that Titans wanted to do they start they
were spreading out the Titans the Titans
were in coverage trying to slow down you
know Kelsey and I reek and the rest of
that crew and all of a sudden you know
Erik the enemy and and eerie decide hey
let's get Damian Williams a little
inside outside zone and they did a great
job of you know short in that second
half and in putting points on the board
and making it really difficult for the
Titans to get comfortable and do what
they wanted to do which is run it do you
think that that could be employed
against the Niners or the Niners are
just too much of a different animal yeah
I think you I think you can't I think
you have to spread them out I don't
think you're gonna mean the Chiefs
aren't built to get into you know 12
personnel on big people where they just
are going to run downhill on yeah I mean
they're they set up the run with the
pass game and when you hope that is the
best
I mean he's unbelievable and what he
allows you to do if you're the cheese
because he extends plays and makes plays
with his feet you know is rocking right
arm you you get everyone spread out
you're worried about the speed so you
start doubling you start playing zone
you know you're trying to keep
everything in front of you and next
thing you know you get a weak box so you
get six in the box instead of seven you
got a man for a man and then damon
wayans is thought and i think that's
what you'll see that try to do tony
Boselli here on the Rich Eisen show what
about the 49ers offensively we saw we
saw Garoppolo only swing his arm eight
times eight times and then rahim most ER
did most of the damage what do you think
about the Niners offense against this
Chiefs defense which is going to be
perhaps the least talked about key for
Super Bowl 54 yeah I think you know go
back to that division round when they
were playing the Vikings and Groppo sued
that pick and I think the number is I
think I got this right it's not right in
front of me but 70 so I don't 17 passes
since he threw that pick yep yeah and
you look at that second half they were
on the ball against the Vikings and they
come out and I thought they were going
to be able to dominate the Packers you
know I don't think they're a great run
defense they haven't been all year
they've been pretty average and they did
and so I love Palestinians
Roch because everyone tries to
pigeonhole him is like your you know
your zone scheme guy you're outside zone
you know you like the play-action pass
naked bootleg do this and he basically
says listen I'm gonna do whatever it
takes to win and he is one of the most
creative run games in the NFL and
they've won multiple ways they've run
they've won running the ball don't want
special run teams in the NFL
their physical front they've invested in
the offensive line just like they have
in the defensive line but they have the
ability also to open it up you look at
that Saints game was like what 52 48
something crazy and and they threw it
all over the yard and Garoppolo was a
reason they beat the Saints late in the
season so they have the versatility and
I think that's due to the fact that Kyle
Shan hands one of the most creative
offensive guys if you have to guy you
have to often snaps Coliseum the 49ers
Andy Reid Eric the enemy for the change
that there's creative in what they do
it's different but they're just
fascinating to watch so it's gonna be a
great matchup I think the key for the
Chiefs is going to be Chris Jones he was
a big difference in that AFC
Championship game he missed the vision
game because of the calf strain he had
we were we didn't think he was going to
play in that game kind of based on the
feel you got on the on the field pregame
but he came out quite limited snaps but
he was a big reason he started clogging
up when he started playing more second
quarter you know third quarter he you
know he was a force bent hard for them
to run the ball I mean really difficult
for the Titans and he's one of the
better defensive tackles both in the run
of the pass led the Chiefs in sacks so I
think he's critical and how they out the
49ers handle him and so you know we're
all gonna be fascinated by this 49er
defense Chiefs office and that's all the
talks going to be up going a Super Bowl
but as you know in these games in these
Super Bowl games it's really it's the
unknown player it's like which secondary
player is going to step up in this case
I think it's going to be on the two
sides of the ball no one's talking about
Chiefs defense
49ers offense who can win that battle
because we know the strengths but these
two units going at it I think who gets
the upper edges and go a long way up
well I have the actual number after
Garoppolo threw that interception
against Minnesota he has thrown the ball
only
14 times 14 times 14 that's they ran it
they ran it 28 of their final 34 non
kneel down snaps in the game against
Minnesota and then they did what they
did against the Packers it's amazing
it's it really isn't it but I guess when
you've got the horses up front I mean I
imagine a lineman must love it right
love it right I love this team so number
one John Lynch is one of my really good
friend own since college played against
each other worked out in college and
kind of going to into our pro careers
I've known forever but here's the
defensive back and look how him and Kyle
built this team they've invested and
happens started a couple years before
even John got there but they invested
for first rounders they rotate through
the defensive line they paid me for to
pass rusher so they have this defensive
line that can rush the passer and play
the run and they I think they have three
or four first rounders on the offensive
line I mean this is where you win the
game I'm convinced I mean you have to
have a quarterback in Holmes is top you
know one two and grop loads in the upper
echelon I mean he's top 10 quarterback
top two well right around there so you
have to have that guy but after that
rich if you can't control the line of
scrimmage you I don't think I think it's
hard to win in the team to get this far
year in a year out of the teams who can
control the line of scrimmage and I love
the job Lynch and Kyle fan said listen
we're gonna invest in the big guys and
that's how we're gonna win football
games and that's how they've done it all
yeah Tony Vercelli here on the Rich
Eisen show the most experienced
individual when it comes to being in the
playoffs and having been to the Super
Bowl before even with just the one spot
it's Andy Reid
I mean 28 postseason games as a head
coach Shanahan's just the first two this
year but you know he is so wise beyond
his years I don't know if you saw the
NFL Films footage from the NFC
Championship game Tony where Kyle called
the play out where he goes up to the I
guess was a decide judge was it or was
just an official right there in front of
him to basically say my guys gonna run a
pattern he's gonna get held by and he
pointed out the exact player who's going
to hold him and that did in fact unfold
and
the hold was called because it was
obvious but he also gave the official a
heads up I've called this play he's
gonna run this route and he's gonna get
held and I saw that and I'm like oh my
gosh I mean what what a what a
remarkable asset that is for a team Tony
well I mean listen he's he's been doing
this since he's about he came out of the
womb right every training campus that
it's part of he's on the ball boy
I mean dad's one of the great coaches
back-to-back Super Bowl champion with
the Bronco Denver Broncos and so he was
learned and he's been around it and he's
you know started you know I love that
you know you know everyone says oh it's
nepotism and all this stuff well Bob
wiseguys a great coach and he started
you know at the bottom and worked his
way up and he's had success in multiple
places and he's grown as a coach I think
you know while this is you know his
first you know experience as a head man
in the playoffs in the Super Bowl he's
watched his dad he's been around it he
had the experience at Atlanta that was
devastating the way that game ended
against the Patriots and so he has
experienced maybe not as the guy but
being or in the situation is as a
coordinator and being around his dad and
I promise when I guess I would be
shocked if it's not that he's he's
bendin is his dad's here and picking his
brain been in these games and I've seen
it and so I'm really wildly impressed
with Josh and what he's doing and just
the whole organization of how they've
really kind of built this thing and to
me it looks like it's built for long
term success
Tony Boselli here on the Rich Eisen show
fans of this show are gonna get a little
sick of it by the end of next week but
I've kind of touched around the edges
here and I you know I might later on
when Paul Rudd joins here as well since
I know he loves mahomes as does
everybody in Chiefs Kingdom part of me
just deep down says no matter how good
the Niners are and they are so very good
they're so very good that mahomes is
just you can't say the great equalizer
he has the ability to be the huge
difference maker in the same way that
Andy Reid's clock management issues from
all those years if poof disappeared any
problem that they had
you saw in the AFC Championship game
they totally blew that fake punt I mean
the whole world knew that something
might be up and they totally fell for it
they took the banana in the tailpipe and
then gave up a touchdown and Damian
Williams run Damian Williams runs out of
bounds when they get the ball and
essentially Eric and essentially gave
the Titans a timeout that they'd already
used back who's the guy that erases all
that Patrick
mahomes who's the guy who scored at the
beginning at the end of the first half
that you said was such a difference
maker it's mahomes I talked me out of
not getting too crazy about that this is
mahomes his moment Tony I can't I mean
he covers great quarterbacks cover a lot
of sins by everyone else I mean they
like just just blanket all these
mistakes and all these tough situations
that the average team can't get out of
great quarterbacks in the homes is a
great one and you go back to the year he
was drafted geez were sitting at 27
they have Alex Smith their playoff team
and I give the whole front office in
Andy Reid and everyone else innovation
so much great they traded a bunch to
move up 17 spots for a kid out of Texas
Tech that was on an average team that
not a lot of people are talking about
because they saw some they were right
because this is a kid who has the
leadership ability he has the charisma
he has the athletic ability he has the
big arm he's smart you listen to how his
teammates his coaches talk about him
he's remarkable and I can't talk you out
of it
the only thing I will say is this we've
seen great offenses in Super Bowls
before I'll go back to one of the
greatest offenses ever on the one of the
greatest teams ever the 18 and OH
Patriots mm-hmm and they look mortal
because of four guys because the four
guys rush the passer for the New York
Giants were all over him all day and he
never got comfortable never could set
his feet and it turned into a
low-scoring defensive game and I think
I'm not saying it's gonna happen but the
49ers are built that way they can
pressure with for Robert Sala can play
coverage with seven in that three deep
zone
in force mahomes be patient and hold the
ball a little bit and if that rush can
get there I think you could have a lower
scoring game than we have than we expect
now the difference we've seen the Holmes
and Brady both great Bray's you know
well you want to talk about what he's
done but mahomes can move and can he
nullify and can you equalize the rush
because of his athletic ability and buy
time if he's able to do that in extend
place I think the Chiefs win if that
rush can get there
I think the 49ers won Tony basella here
and the Rich Eisen show a couple more
minutes left you referred to that o 7
Giants team their quarterback retired
today do you think Eli Manning should be
in the Hall of Fame Tony boy you know
there's great players and Eli Manning
here's all right look at it Eli Manning
when the greatest postseason
quarterbacks ever two-time MVP leading
the Giants to Super Bowls the detractors
are gonna say yeah he's 500 in the
regular season can't argue that but if
you look at the story of the NFL the
great moments great players who played
big and great moments and over a long
period of time because we did it for 16
years I would say yes that Eli Manning
is the Hall of Famer we'll be in Ken one
day well I hope you hear your name this
weekend and certainly it would be neat
if it was with Lynch since you said you
know for so long that would be
incredible man as long as I hear might
get a knock on the door it'll be
incredible but you're right it would be
it'd be a little bit something extra
special because John took the trend and
someone I'm always been rooting for him
converting for for a long time so I'm
excited for him being the Superbowl and
what he's done with that team and I hope
both of us get into the home and me to
Tony and you've been great I'd really
enjoy listening to you on the radio you
get better and better every year it's a
terrific listen and you know we'll
definitely be knocking on your door in
in short order hopefully next week see
you in Miami that's Tony be selling
Westwood one for more of the rich
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app